triste rossignol c'est vous qui avez
parlé de politique politicienne
je vais donc me permettre pour une fois
de vous répondre en politique
politicienne madame la sénatrice
baladins sénatrice qu'est ce que
j'aurais aimé que de votre questions
surgissent une idée une proposition
allait une orientation générale à
laquelle ni la france ni l'europe ni les
états unis n'aurait songé pour lutter
contre la pandémie la plus meurtrière de
notre histoire contemporaine
madame la sénatrice qu'est ce que
j'aurais aimé un mot pour les français
solidaires fort fort contre vents et
marées et qui attendent de leur classe
politique non pas qu'il fasse de cette
lutte contre l'épidémie je ne sais quel
marchepied vers je ne sais quelles
élections à venir mais bien un grand
moment de capacité à faire preuve d'un
minimum d'unité nationale madame la
sénatrice qu'est ce que j'aurais aimé
que vous ayez l'honnêteté de rappeler
que semaine après semaine j'étais ici
dans cet hémicycle pour rappeler à la
représentation nationale que l'épidémie
n'était pas finie que nous avions pas
terrassé le virus et que nous devions
rester armée tout au long de l'année au
pouvoir lutter contre l'épidémie mais
non vous vous livrez par votre question
à une nouvelle attaque en piqué une
nouvelle attaque en piqué madame la
sénatrice
on ne sauve pas des vies avec des
attaques politiques on ne soutient pas
les soignants avec des attaques
politiques
on n'encourage pas les français à tenir
bon dans cette période difficile avec
des attaques politiques avec des
attaques politiques avec des attaques
politiques comme celles que vous faites
avec la polémique permanente que
certains essayent d'instaurer un moment
où nous avons besoin de solidarité et
d'unité nationale
je ne crois pas madame la sénatrice que
vous ayez participer et aider votre pays
dans la lutte contre l'épidémie en
soutien des français
[Musique]